oh yeah well you saw we're talking about
cash now anyway so we got cash
cash there's another video this one
stages of targeting and how they affect
you today
of course that means we need this
all right cash what's up hey guys it's
cash and i'm here today to talk about a
few things
um let's start off by talking about the
pandemic induced recession that we are
now
in um i heard it on the news yesterday
and i also read it in something today
they don't like to use the word
recession because they don't like people
to panic
but they are now officially using that
word
so now we have biden in office
and he is signing a whole bunch of
executive orders he's got us back into
the paris deal
people are saying that that's going to
raise gas prices
um and then he also wants to give
us the remaining 1400
of the proposed 2000 that trump was
going
that trump had proposed so it kind of
makes
me believe that the past two and a half
months
since this election that everybody's
life has kind of been put on hold
you know places restaurants have been
shut down
bars nightclubs things like that so
everybody's life
this second round of lockdowns was put
on hold
to essentially make joe biden look like
the hero i mean yes you're right cash
but that's like
everybody's saying that it's very it's a
very basic take
that joe biden is now president and
you know everything is now miraculously
going to be okay
he's going to embrace us in his loving
arms and
just hug the world um
and for me
that just doesn't really sit right with
me because
they are now playing with people's lives
they're playing with people's incomes
um the way that they take care of
themselves
so this man can look like
the second coming of christ i don't know
um but it just doesn't sit right
with me um so let's talk about a few
things that i
experienced in my targeting situation
in the situation that i went through in
miami here we go so the first one was
confusion because i did not know what
was going on
probably the booze and the drugs don't
tell anybody
but it was probably the booze and the
drugs the second phase was isolation
okay that's when like my friends started
acting weird
i kind of started to withdraw a little
bit and in that isolation phase
was when i started watching youtube
videos
at and just filling myself with all this
information
that i wouldn't have normally taken in
so during that time um of isolation
phase it was like a subtle brainwashing
going on with all this information um
and then of course in the isolation
phase you know you're alone
so then comes the drug pushing so i
would get like subtle like oh
try this and i'm not really a drug
person
like that i don't partake in that kind
of stuff but i see
that is what is happening today with the
commercials on the tv and the
the ketamine suggestion
and then the financial crisis so for me
my finances were up and down i'd have a
great week and then
i'd have a terrible week yeah because
you're [ __ ] talker
sometimes that happens
and then a great week and then a
terrible week so
um it kind of just created this
this sense of instability for me
um and then the final phase of this
is with what they want to get you to
i'm sorry uh oh
were they targeting her live did someone
just try to target her live
right now
uh oh uh oh
it's my dog what they want to get you to
is homelessness and
thankfully for me i do have family
members and stuff
but if i didn't have a family i'm not
really sure what i would do
and that leads into this whole blm thing
you know
they're they want to get rid of the
family unit
that's what they attack is the family
and that's another reason why i don't
support them is because
of the attack that they have on the
family like you see people on
the news right now turning in their
family members that were going to
protest
like that is a blm move
to destroy the nuclear family
to break up families but you're a hooker
[Music]
because if they break up your family and
they make you homeless
well then you're basically under their
control and they can
put you in with human trafficking or use
you for
whatever that they really feel like
using you for um
so it goes confusion
isolation so for everybody else
isolation phase was obviously this
pandemic
these lockdowns you know you're probably
taking in more
news information than you normally would
um and then i know what you guys are
saying her talking points or whatever
but is this
ask yourself a question here and she's
saying some stuff that i do agree with
but ask yourself a question
is this the person you want to be
representing your thoughts and views
[Music]
the drug pushing the commercials i
talked about it yesterday with the
ketamine
ketamine is not a drug ketamine not
ketamine
i don't know who can amine is but what
about ketamine
who's pushing ketamine did i miss
something maybe i did but
are we recommending ketamine now to
people ugh
i've never heard that be prescribed
for anxiety and depression if you know
anything about ketamine it makes you
stuck
it makes you literally just you're just
there
she looks like she'd be an expert at it
no and i feel
like you're right you know what sinister
you're right ken is mean
by them putting that commercial on
between every segment
of a program they want people to be
stuck
they don't want people to know what is
going on right now so they want
everybody on drugs
so the easiest way that they could do
that cash is on drugs everyone
let's recommend everybody take ketamine
and then buy the
ketamine there's a t
time before they know it will have gone
through
with this whole plan um then financial
crisis
here we are right now manufactured
pandemic
did we really need this second round of
lockdowns did we really need to shut
everything down again
no i really don't think that we did i
think everybody has right
you're right hey you're right when
you're right you're right i love the
beer bug and of how to prevent it you
know where face mask
social distancing and things like that i
do not think that we needed this second
round of lockdowns
and it's also very suspicious to me that
now that biden's in
office now all these democratic cities
are lifting up all these lockdowns
um and then homelessness
um hopefully it doesn't get to that
point she really should be an infowars
reporter now that would be amazing
for some people but that is where they
want to get people
because in that state they have complete
control over you you're totally at their
mercy
um and i know a lot of people probably
don't want to hear
this but they make money off of you
when you are homeless in california they
are making money
off of their homeless population
so the one thing that this how
this all leads into and that this is all
done for
is control they want complete
control over people and their lives
and you're seeing it play out right now
right in front of your very eyes so
hopefully people start
waking up and realizing this and
standing up and you know that's why
they're trying to cut off
our speech and they're censoring us
because
people are standing up people are
talking okay look
guys look she's right about some stuff
i'm not gonna be a dick and just because
i think she's crazy tell us
she's just right about something she's
saying she absolutely is
but you're still also a crazy hooker it
really is
more into what you know
oh god some of the oh my god
here you go i got one for you hey guys
it's cash and today i have a reading
from
exodus chapter 32.
okay before we continue this video
there's a couple things i want to read
out read for you okay read for you
i'll point out for you you have a
prostitute here and this isn't making
fun of her she's a prostitute
a prostitute with her cleavage out
about to read from the bible
2021 is gonna be an amazing year we're
off to an amazing start
right we are
off to an amazing start
[Music]
verse 12 why should the egyptians say
it was with evil intent that he brought
them out to kill them
in the mountains and to wipe them off
the face of the earth
turn from your fierce anger relent and
do not bring disaster
on your people so with that
reading and i used to have a very
big divide between reading school she
got big something honey but it ain't a
[ __ ] divide
i'm sure and
putting it with my life and
understanding it but now
the more and more that i do read it i'm
i'm having an easier time
comprehending it and putting it into
my life you saw her move her hair on
purpose to make sure that her cleavage
was front and center
so that's a good thing um and
with that reading i kind of feel that
we are a nation that is divided
conservative liberal
if you're living in a place where there
is a high population
of liberal people such as miami
or orlando or austin texas and this
this bit of information came to me when
i went to austin texas
i realized um
the the link between
austin and miami
and getting stalking it can be what link
is there between austin and miami
there's two different kind of hispanics
also used as
a political strategy as well and
it's almost as if to keep conservatives
from spreading conservative ideas in
2021
[Music]
we have a literal prostitute
telling you about conservatism being a
conservative
a place that is very liberal
and who are liberals who makes up a
large population of liberals hipsters
so a lot of times when
political parties they want to get
things done they target
the groups that are considered cool or
what's in and hipsters
liberals are what is considered cool
liberals believe
in equality before the law and that's
great i believe in equality as well and
that belief system is going to attract a
lot of minority groups
feminists so that's why you see these
liberals
these feminists um minority groups
all attacking trump now i don't think
he's the greatest president
that we've ever had but i don't
think he wouldn't like you either you're
not a blund
he deserves all of the stuff
that he gets
and i say this i use this as an example
because
being in miami which is a very liberal
place
in 2016 i noticed this shift i noticed
this shift in attitude towards people
that were thought to be
conservative i told you i um i would
have events
and i would see maga hats people would
just be wearing maga hats
i didn't even vote i kind of fall in
the mid-range look hey man a lot of
positive stuff here
she didn't even vote so good for her at
least she's taking herself out of the
equation
of liberal conservative i'm kind of like
at a middle ground i understand
the the agreements disagreements of both
groups
but i i haven't really fully committed
to a side but being a white person
none sp spanish speaking you know i was
labeled
as a conservative which
i mean it is what it is but chewing gum
austin texas is where i started to draw
these connections
because i saw they also have a large
hipster population
i saw um in my gang stalking there
the gang stalkers are a lot more
friendlier
i saw the hipsters there's friendly gang
stalkers
[Music]
huh connection and then there was
another connection
that i made there but i'll save that for
another day
um but really
it's it's turned into chaos and it's
turned into oh
you voted for that person like this this
politics shouldn't be able to divide
families
and you know make people just bring out
the absolute
worst in people like there's obviously
something wrong
with this system if it's bringing out
people to feel that they have to stalk
people
and to feel like it's just increased
she makes like points that i agree with
but then like there's this big dip where
it just
then it's like you know all these
political divide and family coming apart
it makes people want to [ __ ] gank
stalk you
dude come on
the hatred amongst people
for the worst so um i've noticed with my
game stalking
my electronics are monitored
i will post a meme or i will make a meme
not even post it it will be in my
phone and that
is being used in my harassment campaign
so even if i take a photo and do not put
it
on the internet it is also being watched
so i do believe that there is a
political aspect to my targeting
as well as other factors
that play into it but you just said you
didn't vote
so why would there be a political aspect
to your fake i mean you're totally real
dry cleaner
cia stalking so
yeah so a lot of things spiritual
spiritually psychics
they go after psychics because they
don't
want people understanding and
knowing what is going on
today so if they can keep you
stuck under your trauma in a traumatic
state
it's going to block those pathways
you're not going to be able to get
messages all right so here's what we
have
i didn't think i was going to do this
today but i guess i am so here's what we
have
so
we have
[Music]
cash
i know it'll look like her in a second
oops so we have cash
bush okay
so we have cash and she thinks that the
cia
is stalking her
because
she thinks the cia is stalking her
because of magga
it's her maga hat um
she thinks this this is why the cia is
stalking her
so the cia i should use that's not the
brush i want any better brush
um
whatever this is fine the cia
[Music]
is stalking her
because of the maga hat she's wearing
okay
that's what it is and they are looking
at her phone let's draw a
phone here
because of her this is her iphone
when she takes selfies for herself
cia
is reading those selfies and then giving
them to their her
friendly because remember she has
[Music]
friendly gang stalkers you can see
they're friendly because look this guy's
smiling
he's a happy gang stalker
[Music]
and yeah he has binoculars
sure but look how happy he is with his
job
okay so the cia is getting the
information from the phone and the
friendly gang stalkers
from here let's do this from austin so
he's a cowboy cowboy gang stalker
is using that to gang stalk
her
are we good
are we good i mean i really looks like
cash that's not bad that's a pretty good
cash picture
so is this where we are right now
we'll continue our video but i just
wanted to make sure we were in the right
place
yes so that's another reason there's
just so many reasons
for gang stalking it's political
spiritual
um for
the the um benefits of the larger
dynamic you know there's just a lot of
different factors that play into
different reasons for targeting
people that are covering political
elections journalists
find themselves being targets
targeted individuals so
it's just about control it's about the
control of
information that gets out it's about the
control of people that can
tap into things that can access
things that can influence people
to sway them away from what the majority
is trying to do and they're trying to
push this
this liberal you know and everybody
should be equal we should
love everybody but
they're trying to take god out of the
equation and i think a lot of liberal
people
are buying into this thing not realizing
what
hand that they're feeding into it's kind
of becoming
like politically even a battle like a
spiritual
battle as well so
with that said um i hope everybody has a
wonderful rest of their day
and god bless god bless
god bless to you cash
[Music]
um i thought b was crazy then you
explained that and now it all makes
sense
no problem i i got i i do my best to
really get you guys to understand
if you just watch it without any
understanding or without any background
of course you're gonna think she's crazy
you know um
oh one more i wanted to play this one
hey guys it's cash and i am here
new location fabulous chair i just have
to do a video in it
um so today i want to talk to you guys
about
technology and how it is
number one thing used in targeting
and gang stalking situations okay okay
so i don't know
what's going on with these phones
with social media you know i've been
hearing a lot of things about these tech
companies
that have programs that run from a super
computer
and can connect to your phone you know i
don't know if
they're listening on these phones at all
times
um but there's there's just been so many
weird things
um in a synchronistic nature but then
also
things that are like there's no way that
this is a synchronicity like
this is planned like this all right hold
on
so
there is see how we do this
satellites
that are picking up what she puts on her
phone
and then it goes to a
[Music]
supercomputer
and you can tell this computer super
because it has a cape
see that's how you tell the computer
super
because a computer has a cape
so
say let's see here
super computer um
[Music]
i don't like that brush i prefer that
brush
okay so so it goes into the super
computer
and then that computer
does like an equation so let's be like
you know
two plus
two equals
nuts and then they get that information
okay and they give it to her
friendly gang stalker see there you go
friendly gang stalker
and then he in turn of course goes back
and he stalks her with the binoculars
he's friendly though you can tell he's a
friendly gang stalker
because he's like
he's like howdy see
that's how you can tell he's friendly
because because he's like howdy partner
let's see here
see howdy partner
and of course we go on and we go all
over and over again like snitches
uh let's keep going is
being like acted out in front of me so
what i'm talking about is
like if i'll let's say i meet a new
person
okay so you know i have a conversation
with this person i don't know if it's
being picked up on the phone
or whatever but then all of a sudden in
my instagram explore page
there will be memes flooding like oh
you know you shouldn't trust people
right away he's a bad egg or
like something like that like along
those lines like manipulating me to like
not
trust that person and it's happened like
so many different times in so many other
situations
another time i can tell you guys about
was i was writing down to the keys
with a girlfriend of mine girlfriend
and not a girlfriend um and
she doesn't want you to think that they
were scissoring which honestly would be
the coolest and hottest thing you could
say
it would redeem you a little bit if you
were just scissoring with her all the
way down
we were talking about something oh the
window
like i lock my windows because i just
don't like them going down when i don't
know about it
so and because of my dog too that's why
um so we were talking about that and
she shows me on her phone not even on my
phone so this isn't even my phone
she shows me a meme on her phone she's
like oh my gosh we were just talking
about that
and it was like paris hilton and nicole
richie riding in a car
and the meme said um you know you talk
about all
of this you know corruption and stuff
going on in the world
and and being controlled but you can't
you know what's funnier than
memes that women like them explaining to
me
somebody explaining a meme is just the
worst way to ingest a meme
let your friend roll down the window or
something like that something along
those lines where it was just like
really weird
that that meme would pop up on her phone
at that specific time
then there's been other times where you
know i've thought about something and
it's
come up as an ad on the phone or i've
literally been eating something
and it comes up as an ad on my
phone and it's almost like is there
cameras in here
watching me at all times like everything
that i'm doing
but um
i want to talk about something else that
happened
just recently you know and it it was a
targeting situation
it was just too weird for it to be
coincidental of course like i said like
of course there's no coincidence in your
life it really doesn't bother me anymore
but it's when there's street theater
incorporated into it
that street theater includes things that
have happened in my life
that's when it kind of creeps me out a
little bit because i'm going to tell you
guys okay so
i just went to lincoln nebraska why
um before i came here why by the way
um so i went to
lincoln and i went to a club and
it was fine at first but
then like there was just a situation
that happened
that i swear to god like i lived that
situation already
i went through that situation it's
called deja vu it happens to literally
everybody
being acted out in front of me
in front of my eyes and
it was just the most bizarre thing ever
and i just wanted to be like
do you people like actually really work
here like is this like
some kind of like set up like is this a
whole thing a movie like i swear i felt
like i was in the truman show
so that was weird that was something
that happened to me
it's called doing too many drugs
oh my god so now she's in the truman
show
a lot in miami if you guys remember i
told you guys
we had a bachelor party big group they
were from pittsburgh
um and then the guy that was getting
married
was the same name as my ex and then of
course
my name and i just felt like that whole
party was meant to just be
like triggering for me and it's like in
in this case it's like what is going on
like how is this happening like is it
being done
for healing purposes is it being done to
just drive me crazy um
especially like with the folds what a
great way
[Music]
so
we is a pole
because she's a stripper now she's in
nick of nebraska
okay
huh and then what is it street
performers
strip performers so
so let's say this guy's a straight
what's the street before you're juggling
like he's juggling okay
street performers are jugglers
juggle lines street performers
he's not happy he's a street performer
performers aren't normally are normally
happy
so he
there the street performers
[Music]
are stalking her at her strip club or a
strip club
in lincoln nebraska
correct
okay we'll continue
you know to have to manipulate an entire
population
is to have people carry things that you
can
literally manipulate them with scare the
[ __ ] out of them with
every day right in the palm of their
hands
so i do have instagram just because it
is
basically just pictures um i was getting
a lot of harassment
on facebook you know so i got rid of
that
i don't have anything else people have
suggested to me to go on tick tock
to go on reddit i have enough with
instagram
and you know right now i'm not private
but usually
i am set to private and it's just so
bizarre
like i just wish that i could figure out
like how
all of this is working you know they are
messing around
it is it is bizarre you know are they it
is
um told me he was gonna beat my ass i
don't i don't think that
that was a gang stalking situation i
just a guy was gonna beat your ass why
would anyone want to beat your ass cash
why
but for the most part um my experience
here
um has been pretty good
so we'll see what happens today
um and yeah
so that's all i really wanted to say um
so i hope
that everybody has a wonderful rest of
their day please tell me
if you know anything about these technol
technological manipulations i would love
to hear
people's opinions on this um and as
always
god bless
you save my artwork
save
okay perfect yeah take that bali i'm the
artist now
a [ __ ] good one a [ __ ] good one at
that